[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Thor Tony check it out
this just got a whole lot more
interesting
[Music]
are you cinema
is that a joke the door make a joke
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
others call them murderers do the
Avengers pose a danger to society that
was the question Bruce that was the
question but that's not how this story
ends
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
well what are we waiting for
please welcome Sean Eska creative
director Crystal Dynamics and Bill
Roseman vice president and creative
director Marvel games
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah thank you yeah thank you thank you
everyone we are incredibly excited to
reveal Marvel's Avengers to the world a
few years ago Crystal Dynamics and
Marvel began collaborating on an
original Avengers game one that combined
epic action adventure with cinematic
storytelling a game where we as players
can experience in both single-player and
co-op what it's like to be Earth's
Mightiest Heroes do I have any true
believers in the house awesome because
you will instantly recognize your
favorite superheroes and villains but
you'll also see that they're unique to
this game as this is crystals
interpretation of these iconic
characters our story begins at a day a
San Francisco celebrates the opening of
The Avengers West Coast headquarters and
the team's custom Helicarrier outfitted
with a strange experimental energy
source however the date turns deadly
when an attempt to steal this new
technology results in massive
destruction blamed for the tragedy the
Avengers are outlawed in our heroes
disband five years later a horrific evil
threatens the world and our only hope is
to reassemble Earth's Mightiest Heroes
you'll play as your favorite Avengers in
an all-new original story showcasing
authentic Marvel heroism and humanity
it's about losing what matters to you
most and fighting to get it back
[Applause]
most importantly this is a story about
self-acceptance in the face of adversity
about embracing our individual powers
and learning that together we are mighty
you'll lead the team as the legendary
Super Soldier Captain America you'll
call down the lightning as the Asgardian
god of thunder sword you'll channel the
anger of scientists Bruce Banner by
unleashing the Hulk
you'll gather Intel and strike swiftly
as the ultimate tactical spy Black Widow
and finally you'll blast through the sky
as the charismatic Tony Stark known to
the wider world
as the armored Iron Man to bring this
incredible story to life we've assembled
an all-star cast I'll let them introduce
themselves
[Applause]
[Music]
so here we are Avengers Assemble
who are you people again hi I'm Troy
Baker and I play Bruce Banner hi I'm
Jeff shine and I played Captain America
I'm travis willingham and I play Thor hi
I'm Lori Bailey and I'm playing Black
Widow
I have Nolan North I play Tony Stark
there's certain characters I don't think
you ever have to be talked into yeah you
know so we'd like to have you played
Tony Stark Iron Man yeah yes you know
everybody always portrays him as this
super confident character I think it's a
mask for him I think he's one of the
most vulnerable guys I think Bruce is
just such a cool character a lot of
people are really quick to bring out the
big green but I think that that Bruce is
super complex character it was fun and
I've never played him before what is
very relatable about Natasha is she's
extremely capable but she's at the core
she's human she's surrounded by all of
this larger-than-life stuff and she has
to step up to it I feel like Thor got
really interesting in the last like 10
or 15 years from for me I like where
he's kind of landed in the public eye
you know one of the things I think is
cool about cap is I never feel like he
he necessarily wants to be a leader he
accepts that he is feeling sometimes the
best leaders are the ones who don't
necessarily want to be but they're right
for the job having an original story to
tell as well what they've done at
Crystal Dynamics is great so I think
everybody's gonna be pretty stoked The
Avengers are at their best when they are
all together but the chemistry is no do
not shake
[Music]
thanks everybody for joining us can't
wait for you to be able to play the game
but right now you don't have to wait for
some exclusive content did the Avengers
pose a danger to society that was the
question Bruce that was the question did
you even check the signs did you it was
a heist Bruce no we were outsmarted the
Terrigen reactor was unstable and you
knew that you knew that and you still
paraded it before the entire world
what we just give up we didn't give up
Tony we failed at least I can admit that
now we failed him we failed him
please welcome Scott Amos head of studio
and Megan Marie senior community and
social media manager Crystal Dynamics
[Music]
[Applause]
hello III you just you've just seen a
high-level view of the cinematic and
character driven campaign of Marvel's
Avengers but launch is only the
beginning of this adventure Marvel's
Avengers delivers a narrative over
multiple years with exciting new content
released at a regular basis like The
Avengers you and your friends are
stronger together you'll assemble into
teams of up to four players online where
you can match four extraordinary
abilities where you can customize a
growing roster of heroes and defend the
earth from ever escalating threats oh
yes oh yes and to make sure everyone
comes on this journey with us we're
incredibly thrilled to announce that
every new superhero and every new region
will be delivered at no additional cost
so our promise to the community is that
we won't have random loot boxes or
pay2win scenarios this game represents a
collaboration across Crystal Dynamics
[Applause]
these guys are here Nixie software our
new Crystal Northwest studio and
everyone at Square Enix so our game is
about embracing your powers and living
your superhero dreams we have an
exclusive gameplay demo in our booths
that will show you more of the core
campaign its original story and our
super heroes in action
[Music]
so Marvel's Avengers will release
worldwide on ps4 Xbox one stadia and PC
we got you covered and we're excited to
be partnering with Playstation to bring
some awesome surprises to the
PlayStation audience including early
beta access and unique benefits that
we'll be revealing in the future
but before we go we have one final
glimpse into our world including when
that you'll get to play this game this
is what's next for the Avengers Thank
You true believers
[Applause]
I have a plan but it's risky hey that
doesn't look ready
come on Tony live a little
[Music]
[Applause]
unbelievable it worked it's sort of cute
when they're small second hang
[Music]
[Applause]